Michael
yes Jane thanks just the context of what
dominic was saying there in the Hessian
region uh there is clearly something
going on we were saying yesterday that
there's been a news blackout from Kiev
and they always do this when they're on
the offensive when they think they'll
have something to report in a little
while and the situation on the ground as
we know it is that the Russians are
holding a line from snehrifka to milova
and they're trying to hold that line
against uh Ukrainian attacks South
moving south against that line and also
the ukrainians are trying to get behind
the defenses of cursing in the in the
south west they're trying to get around
the back of it and they're putting
pressure on the city itself
we knew that that was going on we don't
know what's new although we can guess
and for instance the the Russians have
been saying on social media for weeks
that the 63rd uh mechanized Brigade the
Ukrainian 63rd have been completely
destroyed in this offensive they don't
exist anymore well believe me they do
exist and they're doing pretty well we
won't talk about what they're doing but
they're doing rather well and they're
moving quite quickly and elsewhere
things are happening so Ben Wallace was
in Washington yesterday talking to Lloyd
Austin his counterpart in the states
that's unusual a sudden trip at short
notice the RAF had an rc-135 a river
joint as it's called that's the
surveillance aircraft it was in the
Black Sea yesterday with two typhoons
riding shotgun to protect it and it
spent some time yesterday just going
around in circles literally listening to
everything that was going on on the
coast the uh the the river joint they
just Hoover up everything that they can
get from the ground including the
telephone calls that soldiers might be
making I wouldn't be surprised if there
isn't another River joint up again today
somewhere in the Black Sea we'll find
out probably later on today when we see
to the flight tracks that have been
created something is happening we don't
really know what it is but clearly the
Russians now are talking about
withdrawing uh civilians from Kirsten
which by which they mean the Russians
who want to go and those Russians who
may have collaborated with uh the
authorities and there are queues
building up for the ferries to get out
we don't know how big these cues may
become but clearly the Russians are
preparing to do one of two things in
Kirsten either to withdraw their troops
or to fight for it we don't know which
um the general sirotherkin he is
believed last September to have said to
Putin we need to withdraw we need to
draw a safer line a bit further east
than we are now or we'll be surrounded
Putin is believed to have said no you've
got to stay sarovicin seems to be
softening up with the Russian public
possibly for for as Dominic said either
a withdrawal or a really big battle
around cursing in which maybe new
weapons might be used we'll see
meanwhile the other front is still very
active up in the northeast of the
country of course the uh offensive that
the ukrainians launched at the end of
August goes on they've liberated kharkiv
and the battle now is all about cremina
the road north from criminas the p-66
very big Highway it runs from Criminal
North through satova and North to
droiska right on the border of Russia
that is the main Highway by which the
Russians supply all of their forces
further uh South uh in luhanskondon yet
they can supply them from Russia of
course but this is the main line and
there's a tremendous battle going on now
for the p-66 that Highway the ukrainians
have got it within artillery range
they're attacking parts of it the
Russians are digging in and hanging on
at svato and we'll see how they get on
but cremena is also being surrounded on
two sides at the moment by the
ukrainians there's quite a fierce battle
going on there and a little bit further
south the batmut the Russians are
pushing forward this is the Wagner group
versus the 93rd mechanized infantry of
the ukrainians they're making some
progress of bakmut but it's not going to
do them all that much good unless they
can push right further west than they
probably can't so there's some really
active fighting going on here of course
all our attention is in uh Kirsten
that's strategically more important but
an awful lot of people are fighting
ferociously at the moment for the p66 up
there north of cremina so this battle
this war is entering a new phase as we
get towards the winter the ukrainians
are making a big push to get their gains
nailed down before the weather closes in
and makes operations a bit more
difficult for them Jane back to you
Michael thanks very much well coming up
later here on Sky News Michael is going
to be asking your questions uh you've
just heard from him professor Michael
Clark and it's about the war in Ukraine
if you have any questions you would like
to uh answered seven o'clock this
evening he will be answering those you
can email news at sky.com or scan the QR
code on your screen right now and then
we can put them to him a little later on
tonight